(booming thunder)
- Hello Believe Nation.
I made the Mentor Me series
to try to hang around and
spend a little bit more time
with people who've done a lot more than us
and hopefully their mindset,
their ways of thinking,
some of their beliefs kind of seep into us
to help us become the
best version of ourselves.
So today we're going to
learn from Eckhart Tolle
on the Power of Now motivation.
And as always guys,
if Eckhart says something that really,
really resinates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
could be inspired as well, enjoy.
(soft music)
- The ego, of course, looks for liberation
from its unsatisfying,
unsatisfactory state.
It looks at the ego, knows, this is,
what's, it knows something is missing,
but always looks in the wrong place,
as we already state.
It looks there but never here.
So it never goes deep into life,
into what it is,
it ignores the simple
reality of the present moment
and looks in the, towards the
next moment for satisfaction,
for that which I can add
that will make me complete.
Hence its obsession with future,
with the next moment
and hence everybody lives that way,
almost everybody,
as if the next moment were more important
than this moment
and isn't that strange?
It's a form of mental illness because
the next moment doesn't even exist,
except as a thought in your head.
That's the only absolute
reality that future has,
is it exists as a thought in your head
and it is fine.
As for practical purposes,
it's a helpful thought
that there is such a thing as future,
because it enables you
to make an appointment.
(audience laughing)
So it's helpful,
we got here because of future,
because of this thought that
there is such a thing as future.
But there isn't,
because nobody has ever
seen it or touched it
or experienced it
and since nobody has ever seen,
touched or experienced it,
we can assume that it doesn't exist
and obviously it doesn't,
because when the future comes,
it's the now.
The next moment comes
that you wanted to get to
and finally you get there
and it turns out, well it's the now again.
(audience laughing)
And the ego runs away from it,
not realizing that what
it has been looking for
is hiding here,
no matter what form this now takes.
It is hiding where the conditioned mind,
which is the ego, has never really looked.
It always made the now at
best into a means to an end.
Okay, this now, I need this now
because it enables me to get
to that more important moment,
which is the future, okay.
A stepping stone,
best of times.
All the ego had to reduce
the now to an obstacle
and some people, some people
that is their normal existence.
Every day long, (laughing)
every day long, whatever
comes into the now,
they look at it as an obstacle.
(audience laughing)
Get out of the way, I want to get there.
Every person that comes in, no,
I want something else.
The ego always wants not this,
it wants to use this to get there.
It wants to use every
person that comes into now,
to get there.
So every person the ego meets,
it say, "Okay, are you going to enable me
"to get to the next more important moment?
"How can I use you to get
where I want to get to?"
The now is made into an obstacle.
Or, for the people who are very strongly,
very strongly identified
with the egoic mind,
they make the now into an enemy.
Continuously complaining,
it's never enough.
They should, why don't
they, this is never.
Well, they could go into
the most wonderful place
and after five minutes
they've found the one thing
that's not working as it should
and they're complaining.
They should do something about it,
if not I'm going to do something about it!
(loudly breathing)
And if they're not complaining verbally,
they're complaining in their heads.
(quietly grumbling)
(audience laughing)
They're complaining about situations,
about other people,
about what's happening,
or complaining that's something
that should be happening
is not happening.
(quietly grumbling)
This is, it sounds insane,
because it is insane,
(audience laughing)
but it is not recog, nothing personal.
It is not recognized as insanity
because it is fairly normal
and if it's normal then
it's not recognized
as an illness so that is
the dysfunctional state of consciousness
that is condemned to perpetual discontent.
- How do I,
you know, it seems you
try to stop thinking but
and you read all this
and you try to practice it,
but yet at any given situation,
I find that in order to
get closer to practicing
it or even practice it,
it's causing a lot of thoughts to happen.
So, is that different kind of thoughts
or are those thoughts that I should break
that kind of habit and, if so how?
- Okay, thank you, thank you.
Now the, there's a lot
of talk these days about,
not just talk but actually
it's happening, addictions.
Many people are addicted
to all kinds of things,
substances,
but one of the greatest addictions,
or one of the greatest
addiction never actually,
you've never read it in the papers,
because the people who are
addicted to it don't know it.
It's the addiction to thinking.
It's actually addictive.
Can't stop thinking,
It's like can't stop drinking,
can't stop smoking,
can't stop eating, can't stop thinking.
Thinking is the greater
addiction than any of these
and it's an addiction because it's,
first it's been a drug,
well it's just been around for so long and
it's a subtle sense of self,
so it's,
a great reluctance on
the part of most people
to let go of thinking,
which is equated with the state of sleep,
to let go of thinking.
There isn't that much to
understand in this teaching,
there's a little bit to understand
about how the ego works but even that
is just mainly a self-observation.
The main thing about it is
presence, presence.
And presence is a space of no thought,
but presence can also be
there in the background,
even when thinking is happening.
You can still be not completely
involved in the thinking.
Thinking loses the ability to create
havoc in your life and confuse you so
your choice then is
not to understand more,
or to bring some intellectual analysis
to the practice,
but to practice
the state of not thinking which can be
arrived at by various
ways as you probably know,
if you don't think about it, just do it.
(audience laughing)
Becoming more aware of the present moment
and accept it as it is,
slows down the overactive
mind is one thing.
Because a lot of the
overactivity of the mind is
an attempt to get away from the isness,
the simplicity of the present moment.
So, to become more aware of
the present moment as a practice,
have perhaps a little
pointers in your office,
at home, in your car,
that say present moment or whatever,
or a symbol for it and
and some different entry points
into the present moment.
Present moment awareness means
thinking subsides, may
not disappear completely,
but something else arises that is primary.
We call it presence or awareness,
Buddhist's call it mindfulness,
which I don't use because it implies,
your mind is full of things,
but it isn't of course.
(audience laughing)
It's just a mistranslation, so.
To be present,
first of all, use the
present moment to become,
but how do you become conscious
of the present moment?
Now when you get it,
after awhile you can,
you can actually sense the
presence of the present,
sort of speak, directly
and there it is, choo.
But, helpful things are,
sense perceptions,
take you out of thinking if you're
not judging the sense perceptions,
labeling, naming, looking around.
Anywhere, wherever you are,
look around,
practice sense perceptions
without this compulsive
interference of naming
what you're perceiving.
Oh, that's a beautiful flower,
I wonder what it's called?
I don't know what it's called,
to all that helps I can
be free of thinking.
If I know what it's called,
I can say, oh, that's such and such
and then drop that.
See what it means to perceive without
interference of concepts, words.
In this moment for example,
you're looking at me,
now, let's say,
between now
and now,
were you thinking?
No.
Okay.
And again, between now
and
now, were you thinking or present?
- Present.
- [Eckhart] No thought?
And while I speak, do you
need to think to understand
what I'm saying or can you just listen
and understand it?
- Just listen.
- And this is what you're doing?
And so, that's part of the teaching
and the function of the spiritual teacher,
imparting information is secondary.
What I'm telling you now is secondary.
What is primary is the
underlying state of consciousness
which is presence, that's the teaching.
But you can't talk about that.
It's underlying.
But the, a sign that it's working is
that while you listen,
there's no thought, there's
just a alert presence.
And when the so called teacher
stops speaking for a moment,
the alert presence remains,
it does not need to be
filled with anything.
(quietly whistling)
Like now.
What is there to think about?
Nothing.
Now, if we do this for longer, if I,
at some point,
your mind will probably
start up and think,
well, how much longer is
he going to sit there.
(audience laughing)
And when that happens,
you can allow your mind
to say how much longer
is he going to sit there and say nothing
and then come back to a presence.
And then some other thought will come.
What's this all about?
And then you can allow that thought arise
and then be present again,
which means you're not really,
your priority is no longer
to follow the thought
where it wants to take you,
because the thought
has a magnetic pull,
it wants more of your consciousness
but it wants to grow,
because it's a little entity.
It wants to grow,
so it wants your attention
and in subtle ways he tries
to get your attention.
It says, it might even
use a bodily feeling,
it says, "God, I'm hungry suddenly,
"why didn't I need to eat something?"
And then you think of a,
what restaurant am I going to afterwards?
And so the presence is gone,
you are gone,
you are looking for a
restaurant in your mind.
(audience laughing)
Which means the thought used as
some bodily thing to
make thoughts out of it
completely pointless
because you can't find
a restaurant because you're standing here.
(audience laughing)
But it can use all kinds of
things to manufacture most,
to get your attention
and if you're not careful,
if you don't know the mechanism,
it's not so much an
intellectual understanding
but a simple realization
that this what the mind does.
It tries to pull you in.
It's fine, that's what it does.
Once you know that,
you can allow thought to arise
without following it,
where it wants you to go,
which is into another bigger
thought and a bigger one.
So then you become like,
like my dog when it finds a scent
and when suddenly, even the dog,
when the dog is off leash,
usually she's fine, she
just runs around you,
but suddenly she picks up a scent
and then she goes off completely
unaware of surroundings
or anything, you just follow the scent.
(sniffing loudly)
(audience laughing)
Then she could get lost,
she goes off to the horizon sometimes.
(audience laughing)
Just disappears.
And that's, when you follow a thought,
it goes like that,
you can wake up 20 minutes later,
(audience laughing)
when it started with I was
feeling a little bit hungry
and thinking of a
restaurant and it ends up
with thinking about how
dreadful your life is.
(audience laughing)
"I find myself fluctuating
"between the path of spirituality
"and wanting more material wealth.
"Are these paths mutually exclusive?
Your feedback is much appreciated."
Fluctuating between the
path of spirituality
and wanting more material wealth.
Are these paths mutually exclusive?
If material wealth
becomes your primary aim,
then one could say they
are mutually exclusive.
But if you engage in some activity,
that you truly, first of all truly enjoy,
enjoy the doing
and secondly, you've let activity
that you engage in and enjoy doing,
makes some contribution,
some positive contribution to this world,
to the planet, to other human beings,
add something
valuable,
to life,
increases, perhaps
consciousness on the planet,
then if those two things come together,
then you may find that
as a by-product of that activity,
some material wealth also comes to you
and there's no reason why you cannot enjoy
certain forms, material
form, whatever it is
that come to you
and you enjoy that.
You may,
should give away some of that
and that's enjoyable too
and you mean, if beautiful things come
or bigger things come,
the enjoyment of a beautiful thing
or a house or even a car
is not necessarily non-spiritual.
The attachment
or the excessive preoccupation with it,
with the attainment of it,
that is not compatible,
that it takes you away from
reality, the truth of who
you are from awakening,
but you can be quite present and in touch
with that which is beyond
form and nevertheless
enjoy forms that come to you.
And not in an obsessive way
or if you're wanting to
accumulate as much as possible
of this or that but enjoy what comes,
without identification
with the forms that come,
the house, the car, whatever
the material thing may be.
So in that sense they
are not incompatible.
Renunciation, which
traditionally is recommended
as a path to awakening,
is not, the true renunciation is
not really renouncing material things,
it's renouncing attachment
or identification with,
because many people traditionally,
in many cultures and religions,
who have renounced material things,
didn't realize
that they had not renounced
desire in their mind.
So they suppress, they
just try to suppress desire
and by having no possessions
and refraining another part of course,
renunciation would be,
celibacy for example,
refraining from sexual activity
as part of renunciation,
without realizing that they have,
they spend large part of
the day thinking about sex.
(laughing)
So yeah, that alter renunciation,
is not really the main thing,
the true renunciation is attachment to,
which operates on an inner level.
So you can have a very poor person
being attached to their few
possessions very strongly
and seeking identification through that.
You could have a very wealth person,
not being attached to anything.
Of course, the other way
around can also be the case.
So, it's the inner that matters and
whether or not you're attached
to some material thing,
you can usually, often,
you can may not be able
to really tell it until you lose it,
or it breaks
and so it's always a good little test
when something leaves you
or is stolen or breaks or destroyed.
If then, upset arises,
anger or whatever, then oh,
I was attached, I thought
I was not. (laughing)
But when you can let
go of when things come
and then things go.
Perhaps things come to
you and perhaps often,
well you give it to
somebody else to enjoy.
That's appreciating
beautiful things that you,
a sense of ownership
also begins to disappear,
so you look after something
for awhile and then
it's handed on to somebody else.
There are a quite a few people
who do not express emotions fully,
or don't express them at all.
Perhaps in mostly in Northern countries.
The further north you go,
the less they express their emotions,
that's how it seems to be. (laughing)
Maybe it's too cold to
express their emotions.
(everyone laughing)
Now the practice I describe
of observing your emotions,
allowing them to be,
well somebody who habitually
does not express emotions,
it is not usually the best
way to try and observe
his or her emotions because
they may not even know
what the emotions they are having.
They may be so much pushed down,
so particularly for those people
who have been suppressing emotions,
it is very helpful to express the emotions
if possible without injuring
anybody or yourself.
To allow yourself to express emotions and
witness that at the same time.
So the expression itself
would not free you,
because emotions, if they are not observed
and not witnessed tend to renew themselves
through renewed thinking because there's
this vicious circle of
emotion and thought processes.
So the expression alone,
is not enough because you would simply
be stuck with it and express the anger,
because the anger dissipates
somewhat as you express it,
but if you're not conscious
of the relationship
between your thought
processes and the anger,
the thought processes
will create renewed anger.
And so you would be going to the same
or other therapists
and hitting the pillows
for 20 or 30 years, not realizing that,
through your thought processes,
you're continuously recreating emotion
and you're identifying so much,
so without the presence,
expression is better than repression.
Repression can make you ill.
But to become, to transcend,
it is essential to be
alert and present and
watch it as an energy field,
so that through the watching
it becomes depersonalized
so that you don't feel,
(quick inhaling)
you're not totally stuck in it
and then you can express it,
hit something, not a person if possible,
the pillow if its anger,
or scream and it feels good perhaps
and feel the raw energy of it like fire.
(loudly groaning)
And feel it, wow!
And if you allow it
completely and express it,
it can even very quickly turn around
and then you can do something useful,
that you have enormous energy
and suddenly it gets turned around
and it's just,
it's no longer, it can shift from anger
to just being intense energy.
Okay, now I'm going to clean my room.
(audience laughing)
Not angry anymore, simply with energy.
You could also clean your
room still being angry
but that's not good cleaning,
because you would be cleaning
on the material level
and on an energetic level,
you would be polluting your room.
(everyone laughing)
And so, to become free,
for awhile some people
need to express fully
and then a time comes when,
there's enough presence
and you have expressed it,
then you can gradually more and more,
work on the inner level
and bring presence to it
on the inner, not that
you ever hold it down.
If it wants to and
needs to express itself,
you may do something.
Maybe you can transform
it into physical movement,
vigorous movement or whatever it is,
and watch, but always
be there as the witness.
At some point, you may,
you have find that you have a choice.
The emotion arises,
you can express it or not express it
and it can simply be,
transformed or transmuted
through bringing presence to it.
You will know in the moment
whether it needs to express itself or not.
If you have never or
rarely expressed emotion,
then,
by all means allow yourself to express it
without indulging and
without personalizing it.
Recognizing it as energy no more,
just it's energy and watch.
What happens when you pay attention
to the way in which interact with objects.
And what is, okay,
every minute of the day this,
you pick something up,
you put something down.
You unbutton your shirt,
you take off your shoes,
you lift this, put this there,
open your zipper, bag.
(imitating zipper opening)
(audience laughing)
(air whooshing)
You look inside,
take something out, can you feel it
as you take it out,
can you feel the texture that
and then you put it on the table.
It makes a sound as
you put it on the table
and then you have a glass of water
and the light is reflected in it
and it moves.
Perhaps you drink and it tastes
and you put it down again
and then you look at a familiar object
and instead of using it,
always as a means to an end.
Here you have the luxury of occasionally
just taking an ordinary object
that you handle every day
and just for a few seconds give it,
give it attention and
acknowledge its being
just as that, as that object,
just feel it, see it,
perhaps it makes a noise
as you put it down.
And again you bring in sense perceptions,
getting dressed in the morning,
putting your pants on, they make a noise
as you put them on a little bit.
Do things,
you pick up the toothpaste,
you hold it for a moment, open,
put the cap on the sink, click
and then turn on the tap
(imitating water swooshing)
and then while you brush your teeth
you turn off the tap,
because you don't waste water
(audience laughing)
but that's not part of the
exercise, that's a natural thing.
(audience laughing)
You can actually begin
to like and to enjoy
the tiniest things around you
that would normally be
completely overlooked.
So the way in which you interact
with a world of objects
and that brings a richness into your life
that doesn't depend on
how many objects you own.
You don't need to own
them to interact with them
and so, here you acknowledge
their beingness and
you sometimes you might
just put your hand as I'm doing now,
here's a table, it's wood
and I'm putting my hand on it
and for a moment I feel
the smooth texture, surface
of this table and it,
it feels very pleasant.
But I don't need the mind to tell me that,
I can sense that
and the strange thing is,
even so called inanimate objects,
in a strange way have a life of their own.
"As I'm awakening, I'm becoming more aware
"of how often I'm angry
"and it is getting tiresome.
(everyone laughing)
"How do I manage the
expectations of myself?"
Well, let's see, so man that you need
to manage the expectations
and then you need to manage the anger,
anger management and
expectation management.
Expectation means you beat yourself
up for being unconscious, (laughing)
which is more unconsciousness.
(audience laughing)
Because the mental
image of who you access,
I'm not good enough, I
can't do it, you see?
But been at it for 25 years
and I still can't do it.
You can't possibly be any good
if you still can't do it after 25 years.
Those are thoughts that
float around in your mind
and how do you feel,
well I suppose that's
bar, Katie would ask that,
how do you feel when you
believe in your thoughts?
(laughing)
Not good.
You're beating yourself up
and you feel an emotion.
Feel bad about myself, more ego, more
conceptualized identity in your mind.
Concept in your mind about you,
you derive your sense of self from that,
more of the same.
So the, let's say it's anger
and then you wake up
after the anger reactions,
(sharply inhaling) I did it again,
I'm no good.
So you have the second egoic
reaction to the first one.
(laughing)
Anger is something that is
comes in many people very fast,
so there may not be,
unless there's already
considerable presence power in you,
there may not be enough
presence to catch it.
It takes you all over before you know it,
especially old reaction
(sharply inhaling)
and before you know it,
you're talking and shouting
and you are not doing at all.
It's the pattern, it's the,
the mind pattern, mental
emotional pattern in you,
which often related to
what I call the Pain-Body,
which is old accumulated painful emotion,
which could be anger,
which could be a deep depressed sadness.
Anger is a very frequent one,
as the pain-body energy is just waiting
in people who have accumulated old anger
going back to childhood,
feeling powerless and what does a child do
when the child feels powerless?
It starts screaming, it's all he can do
and sometimes it works,
sometimes the parents come and say, okay,
you can have the sweet,
if you scream loud enough.
So its powerlessness
is always behind anger
and the ego pretends that there's
your power there in anger,
but anger rises out of
sense of powerlessness
and it's a, so they,
and there's often fear
hiding underneath it
and when you, when you
are there looking at it,
then you can, you realize
that at first hand
within yourself, there's
a sense of powerlessness
behind it and the ego's
pretending to be powerful
when really it's in a state of fear.
You can see these with little dogs.
The smallest dogs are the most,
they bark the most.
(audience laughing)
Whenever their, their little,
I've seen little, little dogs
whenever a big one goes past,
they get angry, (imitating dog yapping)
(everyone laughing)
because, I mean if I were that size,
I would do that too probably.
(audience laughing)
So you are, you are a little,
Chihuahua or you're a
little sweet Bichon Frise
and a Mastiff walks past or a Rottweiler,
who looks very quiet
because the Rottweiler
knows its own power.
It doesn't need to, it goes
(audience laughing)
and the little one goes.
(imitating dog yapping)
(everyone laughing)
But with dogs we smile when we see that
because we somehow recognize that pattern
and we smile and probably the Rottweiler
has an inner smile too when he walks past.
(audience laughing)
But with humans it's
more difficult to smile
when they go (growling)
and words come streaming
out of their mouth,
it's more difficult to smile and
but it's possible, not
necessarily you say,
you don't necessarily smile but
recognize it for what it is
when you see it in another.
Don't equate that with who that person is,
recognize it that the
person has been taken over
by that energy field
and that already is a wonderful thing.
That already we could call is forgiveness
is a wider sense.
We don't equate unconscious behavior
with who that person is.
If we equate it with who that person is,
that is, that's the real
meaning of judgment.
Judgment is not to say,
to somebody, I realize
that you get angry a lot
and that person then might tell you,
are you judging me?
No, it's a fact.
If I see that you get angry a lot,
that was just a fact,
there's no judgment in it,
but if I equate that with your essential
identity of who are,
you are an angry person
and then I always expect
more anger from you,
that's a judgment.
Not recognizing a pattern
that apparates unconsciously
through humans and taking them
for their identity is judgment
and you can do it to yourself.
So you can judge yourself for those things
and that is just as much ego
as judging somebody else.
You can beat yourself up
and call yourselves no good
and whatever else the self
talk tells you in your head,
it's, it calls you, you.
In many peoples minds,
when they talk to, the mind
talks to you, (laughing)
it says you, see, you are such and such,
you, see, you can't do it.
Sometimes it says I, it
might say I in some people,
but in many it says you.
Isn't that strange?
You talk to yourself in your head.
One part of your mind condemns
the other part. (laughing)
When you see it,
you can rise above it
and there's a suddenly
an awareness that comes with it,
you're no longer trapped
in those patterns.
I would recommend particularly to become
particularly alert when you
know you're getting stressed,
something, a situation is building up
and some kind of, for example,
if you get, anger takes
over when you get stressed,
it could happen,
when you feel stress
building up towards it,
you can become very alert,
so that you can, doesn't take you over,
when you know the anger is about to,
about to come,
or if it's,
if you know a certain areas of your life
are more likely to break your unconscious,
sometimes you know just beforehand that,
that those are going to arise
in the next minute or so
and then you can be alert,
feel the entire energy field in your body,
be alert with every cell of your body,
then pick up the phone and talk about
the financial situation with
your investment advisor,
so that, and treat those
as spiritual practices
and realize nothing is more important than
consciousness, not the situation,
it's consciousness.
Some people's pain-body's are,
consist as I said predominantly of anger
and you can some, in
some people you can sense
their semi dormant
pain-body in the background
even when their not
particularly angry right now,
but there are people who
are waiting for the next
opportunity to be angry,
that's their pain-body
and sometimes when you,
when you are sensitive towards other,
you can feel energy fields,
you can sometimes sense in other people,
they're waiting for an excuse
to be angry. (laughing)
Some are when you look into their eyes,
it's already there,
but it's not them.
It's that which occupies
their inner energy field,
which the pain-body
and so they're waiting and any excuse
and they will get angry at you
or whoever it may be,
so you become a grievance
looking for a cause.
(audience laughing)
It seems to be there's a
general pattern at work
that it is inherant the
nature of physical existence
of life forms that challenges
our essential ingredient
of their lifespan, here
and part of the way
through which they evolve,
but when they say they
evolve, for here it means,
it's the one consciousness evolves,
awakens into this dimension
through the different life forms
in different ways and
it awakens only because
we are being challenged.
And that is quite a relief
to realize to be challenged
doesn't mean there's
something wrong. (laughing)
There's something wrong with my life,
that shouldn't be.
If you believe or act as if
this shouldn't be happening,
then you get really unhappy.
Then the challenges become transformed
into unhappiness inside you.
You know, if it's not unhappiness,
it's resentment.
If it's not resentment,
it's anger, it's self-pity,
it's complaining, it's
despondency. (laughing)
The simple reason that
you are misunderstanding
the very purpose of life
and expecting something
your mind has come up with
and so be it different.
There is a source of power in you
that transcends the person
and it's not egoic power over somebody
and it's one with the power that
is the power of life in the universe,
where all life arises
and people sometimes have a problem with
self-confidence or valuing yourself
and sometimes you try to convince yourself
by changing your thinking that
you are actually good enough,
that you should be self-confident,
but there is a better way to find
the source of self-confidence.
On the egoic level,
self-confidence is there
because you see, you can tell yourself,
I'm actually more intelligent
than most of these people.
(audience laughing)
Or I'm better-looking that most,
I have to remind myself that
I'm better-looking than most
and then you go okay, yeah, I
feel a bit more confident now.
(audience laughing)
Or you say,
I actually have more
money than these people
so I should, I have more self-confidence.
Whatever it is,
some way of convincing yourself
and then you compare yourself with others
and then you focus on those areas
where you feel superior to others
and try not to think about other areas
where inevitably you
are inferior to others
because you cannot be
superior in all areas.
It's a complicated game when you start,
(audience laughing)
start comparing yourself to other people
and if you want to bolster
your self-confidence
and you only have to
focus on where you feel,
I'm actually better than most,
but that doesn't really work
that well. (clearing throat)
So, there is a better
way of self-confidence
that has nothing to do with
comparing yourself with others,
or with feeling you're better than,
or not as good as
and that is direct
access to an inner power.
You don't need any comparison,
you can have it right
now at this very moment,
if you're not stuck in your thinking mind,
but take your attention
a little bit beyond
the thinking mind
and then realize that you are the presence
behind the thinking mind without
which there could be no thinking.
You're the aware presence behind it all,
that is deeper, you've gone
deeper than the thinking mind
and that aware presence
is where power resides
and it's not yours
because it connects you
with universal power,
therefore you don't
need to compare yourself
to anybody anymore or feel
as the ego always does,
that you're either superior
or inferior to somebody else.
That's not a comfortable way to live,
where you have to classify
yourself when you meet people
(audience laughing)
and so your, the fears always,
I might be inferior,
or behind that fear is
a desire to be superior.
(everyone laughing)
The way in which you communicate,
can be done in such a
way that you don't make
the other person wrong.
That is a very helpful thing,
don't, I was,
staying many years ago,
I was staying with,
in somebody's, when I didn't have a,
I was actually writing,
it doesn't really matter
what I was doing, I was writing,
(audience laughing)
the beginning of The Power of Now,
somebody offered me a
room in his apartment
and he had three cars and he said,
"You can have one of them,
"you can use it,
"I don't use it anymore."
He would always buy the
next, more expensive car,
because he got dissatisfied
with the old one,
so I could, I got one of the old ones
that he was dissatisfied
with to drive around
and it was a beautiful car,
but a few years old.
But I thought, one day I left the car
and there was a signal
when I closed the door
but I didn't realize that
why the sound was beeping
(audience laughing)
and when he realized the next day,
well I wanted to use it again
and the engine wouldn't start
so it seems that the light stayed on,
the sound was to advert me to the light,
but why I'm telling you this is
(audience laughing)
he had done some spiritual work
and I was very impressed
when he left me a note,
'cause he got up before me,
he left a note which said,
"The lights were on and
the battery got depleted.
"You need to call the Triple A to."
That's all and I was very
impressed by that note
because he didn't, a
normal person who had not
done any consciousness work,
would have said you left the lights on,
despite the fact that you must heard
the warning signs of the engine,
(everyone laughing)
so I was able, this
person has some awareness,
he's not making me wrong,
although it was my mistake,
but he's not making somebody else wrong
in the service of being
more right than me.
- Could you please explain
what the divine purpose
of the universe is?
(everyone laughing)
- The universe wants to
awaken consciousness coming into that,
this dimension is the divine purpose,
but the divine purpose is two-fold.
One is,
the universe delights in creation,
it delights in creativity,
it delights in creating new forms.
How do I know that?
Well, just look around on the planet here,
the millions of life forms,
in the sea, on land, the air,
the universe delights in,
in creating this multiplicity of forms
and it delights in experiencing itself
through all those forms,
because you are not a separate entity,
it's not the case as sometimes the ego,
the egoic self believes that here is me
and there's the rest of
the world or the universe.
Or the ego thinks that,
that it is the universe,
it somehow, suddenly appeared,
fallen into this universe and then,
where am I?
I'm in this universe,
you're not in the universe,
you are the universe.
The one life expressing itself
through countless life forms
and there's a growing
complexity in life forms.
(imitating wind blowing)
And with every experience,
the universe is experiencing itself
as your life is extremely
differentiated in human beings.
The way in which life or the universe
or the one consciousness
experiences itself
in this dreamlike world
is extremely differentiated,
it's amazing that every
human being is different,
of billions of humans on the planet,
every human, not only looks different,
you could recognize if you know one person
out of these billions,
and I don't know how many
billions on the planet now,
you could recognize this
person out of billions
of other human beings just
by looking at their face.
This is how differentiated it
is on the surface level already
and then every life experience of course,
there are many similarities
but there's a uniqueness
to every life experience.
Every life experience is a
world that arises and subsides.
My mother's life was,
your mother's life, your parents life,
anybody's life was a particular world.
The way she experienced the
world was very different
from the way I experienced,
it's like my mother and I
and I'm just taking one example
from my personal experience,
seemed to inhabit completely
different universes,
but we were in the same place,
but experiencing life in a totally,
totally different way,
and the universe delights
in that complexity
of experience, so it wants
to experience itself as form.
That means and so the
forms become evolving more,
more complex.
The humans that are alive now
have far greater
complexity than the humans
that were alive 10,000 years ago,
or 50,000 years ago.
Life at that time was more simple.
Gather the food, gather the plants
or hunt an animal if they did that,
prepare the meal, go out hunting,
come back home, so fairly simple.
It wasn't the complexity of
New York City, L.A. freeways
(audience laughing)
and all that's behind that,
nuclear physics, whatever and so on
and so the universe delights in that
and you are an expression of that.
It wants to become conscious
of itself through you
and its doing that,
attempting to do that through humans
but the universe,
that one consciousness
is not separate from you,
you are an expression of it.
But the universe also wants to
know itself deeply, its own source,
it wants the source realization also,
so I know that because I,
I know it by looking within myself,
there is an outgoing
movement into a creation
and there's a return movement
that wants to realize
itself in its essence.
The universe wants both,
it wants to go out and create,
it also wants to realize
its own essence through you.
In human life that expresses
as wanting to do things
in this life, wanting to
contribute to this life,
wanting to create something
and to make something of your life,
your so-called life,
it expresses as that.
The other, the return movement,
so you have the outward
movement of the universe,
the return movement expresses as
coming totally into the present moment.
Stepping away from becoming into being.
Becoming is the outward movement,
what can I do now?
I need to do something,
I want to create this,
I feel that this one,
there's something coming through me.
I feel a piece of music
wants to come through me,
a book wants to be written
or something, whatever, I want do this
or create this, setup this
business or that, whatever
and then it's, it's becoming, doing,
but then there's another
movement that says,
I just want to be
and be still and this present moment,
go deeply into this moment.
I don't need to become anything at all,
I just want to be fully who I am already
and go deeply into being.
So you have, it's almost
this contradictory movements.
In some humans, the outward
tendency is greater,
in others, the inward tendency is greater.
Both are necessary and some or both
need to be there as long as you're here
in the human form.
Both to some extent will be in you,
but there will be different,
to different degrees.
Some are much more going within
and to being to the source,
but I would suggest that
it's not either or,
there are certain spiritual additions
that look upon it as more as either or,
they say forget about the world,
just realize who are and then you can just
sit in a corner for the rest of your life
and never do anything again,
you don't need to.
That's one way but it's,
for us, it's finding a certain balance,
which doesn't mean this needs to be
totally in balance.
A very few humans who are totally balanced
between the outward movement of creating
and the inward movement,
of connecting with your,
with your inner being
at the source of all life,
you need to have both
so that you, the universe
can create through you
without losing itself in its creations.
So you can create,
not from a place of egoic need,
where you depend on the outcome.
Well if I don't get that,
I'll kill myself.
If I don't achieve, if I
don't get famous and rich,
I'll, I don't know what I'll do.
Not that, but a playful participation
in the world of form
and contributing to it,
to the world of form without losing itself
in the creation and in the doing.
If you become stressed it
means you're losing yourself
in the doing. (moaning loudly)
This is more important than,
so you're completely, you become uprooted,
you're no longer connected
to the spaciousness, the unconditioned,
the one within,
so to be and do at the same time,
but some humans, yes,
are much more drawn to being,
I call them Frequency Holders, (laughing)
they hold the frequency
of being on the planet,
they're not interested in creating
huge things out there.
They're interested in doing
perhaps little things,
gardening, cooking, looking after animals,
being with animals, helping
humans in some capacity,
helping even physical, helping humans,
with their bodies and so on.
So they are frequency holders,
they're more into being than,
they're some doing but you cannot,
you always have to do something,
you can't,
but, they don't put the emphasis on doing.
The emphasis is on being
and then they allow
presence to flow into what they do
and they effect the world
also very significantly.
Others have a greater tendency to
performing creative action
and they need to go out
there and become active,
but their challenge is,
not to get lost in what they do
and thinking that's all important.
They forget that this is a play of form
and there comes a seriousness
into heaviness into the doing
and they get unhappy
and when you're unhappy,
whatever you create has some
flavor of that unhappiness
so the divine purpose of
the universe to summarize
my long explanation,
(audience laughing)
is to know itself, most
through the creation of form
and through realization of,
of the formless essence of all life
and that is the divine
purpose of the universe
and that you are here as part of that.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know what did
you think of this video?
What was the message that
resinated the most with you?
What did you learn from this
that you're now going to apply
in your life or your business?
Please leave it in the comments below,
I'm going to join in the discussion,
thank you again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
(booming thunder)